it's been 17 years since since uh hayden
christensen was last seen in a galaxy
far far away that's right fans could not
be more excited to see hayden reprise
his role of anakin skywalker aka darth
vader in the upcoming disney plus series
obi-wan kenobi speaking with
entertainment weekly the actor revealed
what it was like stepping back into the
role
saying well without getting into too
much detail it was amazing it's a great
honor to get to put that suit on yes
hayden says the whole experience was
very very surreal well adding
of his excitement i had spent enough
time with this character and felt like i
knew him and coming back to it felt very
natural in a lot of ways and i was just
really excited to get to come in and
play darth vader at this point in the
timeline because it did feel like a
natural continuation of your journey
with the character and that was very
meaningful for me and hayden also
discussed the first moment he saw ewan
mcgregor's obi-wan again admitting that
was a very special moment for me and one
that i'll remember for a very very long
time now according to the series
director
canadian filmmaker deborah chow she
pitched hayden the concept during an
in-person visit to his farm in uxbridge
ontario deborah tells the outlet
it was really nice because we sort of
met up in canada i'm obvious
obviously with people like ewin and
hayden they've been these characters for
so long and they obviously did them in
prequels and they've lived with the
character in their lives for so long
that they just know the character so
well which makes it so helpful in terms
of the creative it is super interesting
to me the idea that uh anakin us that
anakin that well yeah that anakin that
hayden kristen is going to play anakin
skywalker again um
because you know as far as just the
movies go i know there's a whole lot of
lore with comics and all these things
and novels in between
but um
as far as i know like he's darth vader
after you know the third movie in the
series like he is darth vader after the
third moving series and so for hidden
christensen to be playing him then to me
that means that well we will see him
without the mask and there will be some
story that involves like him and who he
is
and maybe battling that you know the
pull to the dark side that he still has
kind of early on in his career as darth
vader um
i
your eyes are glazing over a little bit
i want to be your partner in tv and like
give you things
but i have nothing to add to this and to
all the fans i apologize but i know i
could feel my eyes glazing and i was
like i love what you're saying but i
but everyone else loves it and i it's
going to be i'm excited me too there are
people that are excited here right
billy kidman says who is obi-wan you
know what
billy call me we'll work it out we just
we should just drive to oxbridge
i want to go to the farm
like is there horses
are there probably
we need to go something like this or
something no we could like be in the
stalls
but that's not what i was picturing oh
but why not i was envisioning that's
like going to the farm and then like
wearing wearing flannel but then but
like flying around and like drinking
coffee or something oh we could do it
wearing flannel dressing i'm not a farm
person i don't know if you could sell i
give you a farm guy i grew up not on a
farm but a round farm so i so you want
to go in there you want to shovel things
well let's just experience the life
or not okay